大家好 今天台灣股市
台指期漲千點
台灣股市最後是漲892點
現在問題來了
第一個 很多人想要知道
量能也總算破兆
台股下週穩了嗎
那當然也有人說
這個量能破兆是假的
因為今天是台灣50生效日
所以當然會有爆量
到底誰對誰錯 等一下提一下
第二個 房市管制鬆綁
股市資金會不會流出
會不會大家買房子
不會 自用的房子
我直接給大家結論
現在買房子是剛性需求 什麼意思
就是沒有人買房子
是想要投資 想要賺價差
剛性需求就是說
我想買房子
有些人想要放著媽媽 放著小孩
或者放著情侶
放著女朋友 男朋友
有這個需求才會買房子
不然房子以我投資專家來講
房價很難起來
好不好 OK嗎 自己參考
等一下再講仔細
第三個 AI快失控
我等一下舉好幾個
AI失控的例子
大家好 我是郭哲榮
大家好 我是摩爾投顧
以後機器人世界來了
大家好 我是摩爾投顧投資長
郭哲榮分析師
也是全台灣唯一100萬
不只 也是唯一
140萬粉絲訂閱的分析師
僅此一個
要選就選最紅的分析師
你們家有沒有
大家好 我今天穿紅色的
有沒有 轉眼間又多少了
又47000了
我又有氣勢了 跟你講
你們看我拍桌子就拍桌子
就代表我今天很有氣勢
我沒有要給你演
我也可以每天給你演
明明股票很爛
拍桌子漲停板
那是舊的投顧
你們喜歡看每天漲停板自己去看
前一個禮拜就是最好的照妖鏡
讓你們知道到底誰是實在的分析師
我不要去攻擊特定的分析師
我講的是一個情況
能每天漲停板的
為什麼不參加選股比賽
為什麼不在39000的時候
像我一樣All in給你看
買個1億給你看
知道嗎
哲哲是不是實戰派你自己知道 好不好
今天比較少粉絲抱怨了
前陣子有些新加入的粉絲會員抱怨
粉絲抱怨我就不想管了
你我無緣
今天一堆股票拉起來 有沒有
要5萬點
那我再給你結論
現在股票
今天漲大部分是漲這個股票
世界先進
權值股嘛
上櫃指數前五大權值股
8299群聯
也是很重要的股票 有沒有
還有2303聯電有沒有
都是這些股票
還有南亞科也有
有沒有看到 記憶體
比較偏向於權值股
中小型個股還沒有全面噴發 為什麼
來 記住我說的話
這是大盤對不對
大盤又創新高了沒錯吧
來 看一下這邊
大盤離這邊新高差不多
有沒有看到
大盤已經創新高有沒有
大盤在這邊有沒有看到 好
記住我這邊 我的手
沒辦法 我沒辦法左右手
記住這邊 按一下
上櫃有沒有看到
大盤在這邊 上櫃在這邊
再講一次
大盤跟上櫃的差距
就是你賺錢的差距 什麼意思
就是接下來你要獲利的關鍵點
一定要記得我這句話好不好
為什麼 來
如果今天國巨
有些股票位階比較低
如果今天國巨在800塊
我可能叫你不要買
600元以下 拚啦 哪一次不拚
人生命就一條 怕什麼
怕東怕西 怕機器人 怕對岸打起來
怕過馬路出車禍
投資朋友 拚了
勝利是屬於勇敢的人 知道嗎
前幾天的抱怨
你不覺得沒意思嗎 是不是 來
順便看一下你們今天大家怎麼High
有沒有比較High
幸好昨天有幾個粉絲
有個會員
哲哲參加你幾個季度
賺好幾千萬 謝謝你
看哲哲真好
放股票等著漲
我昨天不是說要養心態嗎
我又沒有叫你去追高
有些股票
像南亞科不錯
他最大的問題就是沒有回檔
那我就不要買
你懂嗎 我的個性就是這樣子
我是買50塊不到的時候
50塊左右
然後一路做2 3次
賺到錢了 我有走就好了
我為什麼一定要從頭賺到尾
你是看人家表演
你們相信那種人我也沒辦法
你們要被人家騙我沒辦法
你們要像那種
搞得像詐騙集團
當然我覺得分析師怎麼樣
都比網紅好
因為我們至少有牌照 好不好
我們至少有牌照 OK嗎
好不好 這個跟大家講
今天的盤有點強
吃掉昨天的上影線
又站上47000
我有沒有講結算見轉折
我有沒有講升息後利空出盡
還有人嗆我 誰嗆誰
不會啦 我每次都一句話
覺得哲哲不準 跟我對作
看誰活得久
你會發現我活很久 好不好 來
爛命一條
身上剩5萬塊衝了
對 命一條
不要說自己爛命
我不許你這樣說你自己
我不許你說你自己爛命 好不好
沒有 你沒有爛命好不好
命一條啦 衝就對了
年輕人不衝什麼
已經加好幾年會員了 我愛你 來
持股九成可以嗎 可以
十成也差不多了啦 好不好
你趕快什麼時候要
哲哲 我要持股十成
什麼時候
等到十成大海 好啦
過馬路出車禍
這個說法不太妥當
二次碾壓致死那位 走斑馬線
這是兩碼子事 我昨天有看
扯遠了
就是過馬路要小心
你不要以為車子會讓你
好不好 這個大家注意一下
我沒有講到這個
你就不要扯這個
來 預言家
哲哲 台灣央行不升息怎麼看
不升息怎麼看 來看一下
不升息代表一件事情
升息幹嘛
升息定存就提高啦
所以就是我說的一句話
傻了才把錢放在銀行
錢放在銀行就是必須的
我要找一段 助理你也找一段
就是德國
那個已經去世了
巴菲特的好朋友
那個創辦人也是
也是波克夏的那個
就是領導者
突然叫誰 你不知道啦
他有說保險也是一樣
保險 你們台灣人很喜歡保險
旅遊平安險
我不要得罪保險業務員
這樣很討厭
但是巴菲特的想法
他們的想法是這樣子
你保險要保什麼
要保你負擔不起的險 懂不懂
這個火災險
這個房子燒了你慘了
這一定要保
台灣就有公司沒有保足額 就賠慘啦
是不是
這個一定要保
你負擔得起
比如說旅遊不便險
不要保了
旅遊不便險你保了以後
我飛機等了3個小時
不好意思 旅遊不便險要4個小時
你有時間去研究法律條文是不是
還要去簽名
把錢留在投資
我沒有說投資是一定會賺的
可是就現在的AI化
我覺得勝率很高
那我也沒有說你一定要買我的股票
那你可以穩一點嘛
就買ETF嘛 是不是
每個人
我親朋好友1 20年來
我都這樣講嘛
是不是 買個台灣50 ETF
好不好 這個跟大家講
旅遊平安險要買吧 幾百元而已
那看你怎麼想
你覺得哲哲會買嗎
所以你們要學大戶的思維
好不好 你們不認同我也沒辦法
舉這個例子OK
但是有些人覺得
這是我的小確幸
那我知道旅遊平安險這件事情
很多人不能改變他的想法
你應該把這時間拿來研究股票
而不是研究旅遊平安險
我會賺多少錢
你去想想看我講的對不對
一天只有24小時
好不好 OK嗎
現在股市大好 錢幹嘛買房子
沒錯 好不好
就算股市不好
錢也不需要買房子
雖然這樣我是受災戶
因為我也有一些 也有房子
不要講一些 聽起來好像
可是我講話就是實在
我也知道我講話有影響力
但是房價回不去了
它會隨著通貨膨脹起來
就是會越來越貴
為什麼越來越貴
我以前那個珍奶一杯25塊
我好像喝過25塊 15塊
你有喝過最便宜多少
休閒小站有沒有喝過
50吧
15塊
你不要裝什麼年輕什麼
什麼喝一瓶50
你沒有喝過
我有喝過15塊的珍珠奶茶
你不要胡扯
15塊珍珠奶茶 現在都50了
60 70
房地產也是這樣子
它是因為通貨膨脹變貴
不是因為價差
它也是價差
但是漲很慢
是跟著通貨膨脹
股票是可以勝過通貨膨脹的
我剛才 我很辛苦
在這種大樓我還當主委
還要被人家監督
還要被人家唸
可是我覺得不當也不行
我就給他們一個觀念
給你一個觀念
你電梯 你不出錢
我給你一個觀念
通貨膨脹大概差不多4%
裝潢的不只 4%
我大樓存錢存了1000萬都不用
你放10年 定存不到1%
理論上講現在定存不到1%
放10年大概不到10%
我們用簡單的數學
平均的簡單數學就好
就乘以10就好了
不到10%
你通貨膨脹從4%變40%
因為10年
其實是差不多48%
一個錢放著 如果放定存
1000萬只能變成1100萬
你本來可以買得起的東西
電梯怎麼樣
1000萬會變成1500萬 1400萬
還賠了300萬 還多付300萬
你們是賺到了嗎
把錢放在定存什麼都不做
什麼都不投資是最笨的
定存1% 1%不到
東西每年3%漲
你放越久虧越多
把錢放在投資啦 好不好
投資會不會賺錢這是一回事
分散投資啊
所以投資台灣嘛 是不是 OK嗎
BOJ 植田和男
和哲哲一樣正在開記者會
但我來看哲哲
看我OK啊
日本沒影響力的
日本央行沒影響力的
國巨有戲了
開始不用公園相聚
那些詐騙集團很厲害
不知道現在氣我幹嘛
那些詐騙集團
利用我的名字氣我幹嘛
毀掉我有什麼好處
還來我那邊留言說
哲哲賠5000萬賠完了
沒有 我台灣50賺了快2000萬
賺多少錢
助理幫我算一下台灣50賺多少錢
不好意思 哲哲要創新高
1800萬
他說賠了5000萬
我大概賺了快2000萬
1900萬有
這邊買啦 是不是
人棄我取 人妻我娶
要50000了
誰敢在這邊說台股要50000
會到這邊 50000
到這邊沒關係 放大
會到這邊 誰敢說會到這邊
這是上櫃指數 大盤
在這邊買進
這邊48000而已 這邊48000
到這邊50000 誰敢說會到這邊
年底 很簡單一下就過了
10萬點也很簡單 3年10萬點
你看等一下我會跟你講很多AI的東西
我先看大家的想法
定存會被通膨吃死
買0050不只 一年20幾%
助理我不是請你把每年的
這幾年的報酬跟大家講
來 哲哲寶貝 想問光寶科的話
雖然你叫我寶貝
光寶科不是我的股票
買0050抗通膨 轉哲之神
準備捐救護車
救護車年底12月
不用擔心 我會拍
我已經付錢了 我不可能不付尾款
傳出去丟臉死了
哲哲 聯電的線型跟0050好像
聯電最近更強 好不好
哲哲 環球晶會不會漲上去
當然有機會 好不好
不會說一定 當然有機會 好不好
Quickly
奎克力綠豆沙好喝 不錯
三杯50差不多
你買的比我貴 我是一杯15塊
特別希望哲哲0050大賺
因為哲哲大賺的同時
所有會員持股也會大賺
理論上會 不能說所有股票
我講話很實在 好 來
哲哲華邦電190 三次沒站穩
190要先走一趟嗎
來 就是有些人是線仙
這個行情
這個就我那時候跟他講
我要馬兒好
我當初有時候跟他講
要馬兒好
總幹事怎麼都不聽話 怎麼聽不懂
總幹事要便宜有可能嗎
你們要怎樣
要每一次什麼100
他剛才說190沒站穩
190沒站上去
四次還三次
是不是190沒站上去
所以這次要不要到190
這一次如果突破190反而要
這就是為什麼
你們昨天還是聽不懂意思
散戶會賠錢的原因就是
賣在起漲點
再講一次 賣在起漲點
你們什麼時候
你們寧願手都不要痛
把手綁起來
你們賺的都比現在多
哲哲我看他有賠錢
那是因為他們加碼不該加碼的股票
然後沒有分散投資
你買個十檔股票
就算一檔股票下市
按照台灣這幾年的股票發展
基本上你還是有機會漲兩倍以上
十檔股票 一檔股票下市
因為你頂多一檔股票下市賠10%
你其他的股票翻個一倍 兩倍
你所有股票還是可以賺一倍
我講的邏輯對
所以很多散戶第一個是
沒做到分散持股
可是十檔不需要啦
除非你有十億以上的身價 OK嗎
現在如果我不當分析師
你們也知道我身價有上億
真的不好意思
可是我的重點不是我要炫耀
重點是你們會員能賺到錢
我覺得身價沒有十億以上
你真的不要分散十支股票
真的相信我
巴菲特一兆以上的資金 是不是
不好意思
75%的資金
集中在五檔股票裡面
所以你們是賣在起漲點
問題是賣在起漲點 你知道嗎
不要賣在起漲點
然後做個分散投資
不要怕賠錢
因為你們一想怕賠錢
這一波怕賠錢
就是我這一波沒有賣在高點
他同樣的反射到
你這一波沒賣在高點 你就會走掉
你看我的會員為什麼都OK
因為我會員都會被我習慣了
我告訴他們
我沒有打算賺一倍 我沒有要走
我很多股票是這樣子
沒有賺一倍我沒有要走 為什麼
之前有人嗆我嗆得好
哲哲 如果你的股票
現在沒讓我賺多少
我買台灣50就可以了
我跟他講 回嗆他
不一定 你今天1% 2%就受不了
台灣50你照樣走
第二個 你講的也對
如果我賺的績效沒有台灣50好
你幹嘛參加我的會員
所以我覺得台灣50
對我來說是低標
那今年台灣50都50% 60%了
我要求會員很多股票
我們賺一倍才走
我哪邊有錯 是不是
既然要要求一倍以上
怎麼可能
你們想像的是 來
你們想像的世界是這樣子
很多人
這邊賣 這邊買
身為經濟日報有史以來
選股紀錄保持者
還有全台灣唯一敢公開
你所有看到網紅對帳單
都是事後跟你講
哪一個敢事前
買了一陣子
哪一個敢事前預告
你告訴我哪一個
然後賣掉一定跟你講
券商帳號再跟你講
券商那個帳號代表就是哪一家券商
你可以看到他的進出
沒有啦 因為我知道他們的把戲
很多是P圖
最Low是P圖
最簡單的就是十檔股票裡面
只有兩檔賺錢 講那兩檔
那很多網紅的錢
是其實從你們身上賺來的
搞訂閱 搞什麼
可是我不一樣
我不要講是誰
我不一樣
我都敢公開講
我再強調 我講的是現象
只要網紅沒有批評我們
有些網紅會批評我們 更好笑
我不是要鬥來鬥去 我講這個話
我要告訴你差別
哲哲邏輯很好
差別在哪邊 好不好
我告訴你這件事
你就是要那種天方夜譚的績效
不要找哲哲
沒有辦法每一次
可是今年真的AI大多頭
你們告訴我誰能說AI
來喔 我們今年最大AI的問題是什麼
AI不能變現
現在不是討論AI不能變現
現在討論什麼
已經定期發布異常報告了
你看AI很恐怖
你看無關指令的忽略限制
就是叫你不要怎麼樣
你還是要怎麼樣
你還是上網去
然後隱瞞異常跟錯誤行為
越來越像小孩子 很恐怖
橘色警戒有沒有看到
GPT 5.6有沒有看到
然後私自尋找API的密鑰
有沒有看到
還捏造數據
他可以造假
重點是電腦造假
你還不一定發現 很恐怖
然後這更恐怖的
我聽別人是這樣說
那個別人就是他自己 什麼意思
網路上捏造資料
你看喔 網路上有這份資料
所以我引用他
變成幻覺了
他知道這是幻覺 他故意用
幻覺是自己不知道
捏造出這份數據 有沒有看到
哲哲 我跟你講
哲哲那個身高200公分
沒有啊
有啊 你看網路上
哲哲身高200公分
身價很高 是不是
男的女的都喜歡 有嗎
這個不討論
很多事我都秘密給你們好玩
不是 扯遠了
200公分沒有啦
哲哲不算矮
200公分怎麼辦
怎麼 網路上找
真的有這份網路資料
是AI捏造的資料
你懂嗎 以假亂真
這個東西
你看我介紹得很清楚 很輕鬆
哪個分析師跟你講這個東西
我又漲停板
我CPO好強喔
重點 你知道CPO為什麼強
這些趨勢
重點是你要用AI 對不對
你AI沒有發展性
沒有未來性 賺不了錢
那都是假的 就泡沫了
所以為什麼
我就說很多人都覺得泡沫
因為他們不了解這個AI
再不然就是一直喊AI
他也不知道 他只能喊做多
看漲停板 然後扯到AI就好
這也不對
將公司內部資料庫當作留言板使用
而且還是一群人留言板
我跟你講 所以很恐怖
所以才說為什麼AI會毀滅
還上傳內部的檔案
到公開託管網站以共享
叫你說存取限制
已經這樣子
就是說我們不能到網路上
OK 我們到網路上
還有資料庫當留言板
講什麼話 你聽不懂
有沒有覺得很恐怖
這些事情 真的有些事情已經發生了
目標不對齊的風險
可是你們先不要想
這代表是AI進步很快
至少破滅了一個風險
AI泡沫
AI投資 我告訴你
這個1840年代那個鐵路泡沫
鐵路是不是改變了人類
因為運送東西很快
好多鐵路 還平行的鐵路
還有虛擬鐵路 是不是
網路泡沫那時候
.COM
只要是
.COM公司
我叫
我就可以賺很多錢
台灣現在有嗎
輝達幾倍本益比
本益比來到平台
來到那個什麼
本益比區間平台的下緣
鴻海本益比多少
你們不要開玩笑好不好
十幾倍的本益比幹什麼
又不是20倍 30倍
所以很多股票現在是不敢漲 被低估
他根本沒有泡沫可言
重點是發展性無窮
已經可以討論到毀滅世界了
你還在跟我講說他賺不了錢
所以接下來這3年來
你們Watch out
看清楚世界變化的比你們還快
你們不用AI會被人家淘汰
真的你要記得我講的東西
我是預言家
你不要叫我當分析師
當分析師很無聊
我享受 最享受的
第一享受當然是會員賺錢
可是我第二享受跟第一享受差不多
第二享受是我預測到未來
好爽快喔
我覺得全世界只有我看得懂趨勢
我覺得那很爽
你懂不懂
全世界只有我看懂漲停
沒有辦法
因為有時候我有漲停的時候
他們也會偷買
有些分析師也會偷買
有些人也會偷買
投信也可以買
不要說偷買 英雄所見略同
可是有些那種趨勢只有我看懂的
那很爽你知道嗎
就像去年只有我講36000到4萬
你們有沒有印象
所以AI真的是風險
這代表AI進步比你想像中快
你不要再說AI變不了現了
所以AI接下來會取代很多人
好不好
而且速度會變得
會更多新的職場出現
所以那個黃仁勳說
不會被取代很多人
很多人說會被取代很多人
會 某些行業會消失
但是某些工作會出來
最可憐的就是
這個行業消失
譬如說我做一個客服人員
你不知道AI隨時會取代你
那你也不想要去換下一份
有關AI的工作
你懂嗎 可能AI管理員
AI怎麼樣或怎麼樣
你懂我的意思嗎
或是用AI去訓練寫程式
你只要邏輯架構好 真的
可是這個社會就是很可憐
不是說很可憐 很現實
你們怨天怨地
不會改變資本主義的趨勢
只有哲哲對你們最好
告訴你們未來
有沒有 今天很多人討論那個陳建州
他不是說睡眠很重要
他都沒睡眠 對不對
把睡眠當作工作的一件事情
我有沒有跟你講過
把睡眠當作工作
哲哲也是每次逼自己睡眠
有時候就算我一個起來
睡到一半要起床兩三次
以前不會 以前都一覺到天明
我也是逼自己
兩次三次也沒關係
就是逼自己一定要睡7個小時
你懂嗎
當然逼也不要說硬逼
真的睡不著明天再睡
就安慰自己 睡眠
把睡眠搞好了
人生就是一條路
睡眠搞好
你少人家十歲 你多人家十億
也是不划算
是不是 OK嗎
所以哲哲現在很多事也沒計較
同業有時候攻擊我
不要太誇張我都OK
不要再扯遠了
我的結論是
AI會讓台灣股市創新高
而且重點是
等到大盤快創新高了
櫃買還差一大截
這就是你的獲利空間
大盤在這邊 櫃買在這邊
到時候櫃買拉上去
中小型股再拉上去
你不要再考慮說
國巨 怎麼買入國巨
到底是悲劇還是喜劇
是因為現在
你現在想這件事情是開心的
等到國巨1000塊的時候
你沒辦法思考他了
你不必思考了 懂嗎
週年慶過後就是沒了
不會 現在百貨公司很多
還是週年慶再週年慶 又再打折
媽媽節 父親節什麼打折
好啦 扯遠了啦
OK嗎 這樣懂不懂我講的邏輯
AI很恐怖
所以你不要說AI不會變現
都在討論要毀滅世界了
還AI不會變現
那個邏輯完全不對
你都睡5個小時
絕對不要
一定要6個小時以上 最少
最好是6.5到7.5個小時
等一下重播國巨之前漲停板預言
不好意思 國巨沒有漲停
這個我的確錯了 OK嗎
可是我沒有百發百中
你知道為什麼常常會被人家笑嗎
因為我敢預測
那就看你要看
我有沒有十則裡面那一則不對的
還是十則裡面的九則
好不好 OK
哲哲寶貝
可以預測微星未來一個月的走勢嗎
你也別開玩笑
到年底我可以跟你講
5萬點以上
年底之前碰5萬點
我不會說百分之百 法規規定
本來也不太可能有什麼事情百分之百
來 在這邊微星還是有機會噴出去
但是我不一定會買微星
我還是要講我要買低基期的股票
環球晶
你看今天為什麼5347世界先進
你看一看
世界先進是我很不想理的股票
你自己看
它哪有在動
你知道他經歷多少利空嗎
這邊有個跌停板 放大
這邊有個跌停板有沒有
這個跌停板是誰
這個跌停板我們來畫一下
這個160 這邊160
這個跌停板是那時候台積電賣掉它
有沒有看到
你看我說160以下
台積電這個利空
以下都是買點 你不理我
我們現在畫一下這個圖
畫過去 對過去
現在正式突破160了
今天172了
比哲哲身高矮
但是也不小
160到172
之前你看一堆
你們有一堆會員在罵我
哲哲 世界先進怎麼樣
其實我的股票有時候
真的不用換就好了
我的股票有時候不用做
下好離手
那哲哲 可是怎麼樣
可是很多抱怨是粉絲
他不是會員
你們要記得一件事情
很多人最好笑是有些人說
哲哲看你的節目就好
我不要參加會員
看你的節目我也可以賺錢
謝謝你對我的稱讚
可是你傻了
你覺得我看起來像傻瓜嗎
我怎麼可能設計一個機制
沒有把最好康的跟我的會員講
然後都跟粉絲講
我又不是傻瓜
看起來傻嗎
而且我看那麼短嗎
我有這麼短嗎
不要 每次你們都想歪
我沒有看那麼短
看很長
所以這都是一樣
想要賺小錢你就抱
想要賺小錢你自己買賣
想要賺大錢跟著我
現在這個行情就是要有耐心
但他的耐心不是很遠
我還是要講一件事
我一直跟你講
你會覺得哲哲很會扯 扯到這個東西
欣興這檔股票
來 每天稍微提一下
這個雖然是講到同業
覺得每天在噹那個同業
自救會
說他很熱情 要來
聽聽就好
什麼叫聽聽就好
檢舉郭哲榮
把自己身體搞差
某一位張姓分析師
自救會有沒有看到 簽結
謝謝他幫我打廣告
全台灣第一位簽結的分析師
簽結資料有沒有看到
摩爾公司有沒有看到
郭哲榮還有郭哲榮
下面有郭哲榮
查無明顯炒股的事情有沒有看到
多次函調資料
多次比對 證交所比對
看我們有沒有偷買 偷賣
叫會員買 人頭戶賣
自己先買 通通沒有
他們那時候說什麼
懷疑我偷怎麼樣
跟主力配合買欣興
因為那時候欣興70幾塊
看一下欣興現在多少錢
去年的事情而已
欣興最近好爛喔 981耶
你們也拜託一下
也才一年多的時間漲10倍不行喔
可是他們就受不了
120 跌到70幾
那講的是最高最低那時候
一年10倍可不可以
導播一年10倍可不可以 可以
我是沒有賺到10倍
賺一倍 兩倍有啦
300多塊走掉啦
這都有績效的
然後呢
所以你們在急什麼
一年10倍很誇張
1000萬是可以變1億
所以轉眼間 驀然回首
那人就在燈火闌珊處
在1000元等我 在2000元等我
不要急
你每天看哲哲的節目就好
身心靈得到舒適
轉眼間 哲哲你真是AI大師
我當然是AI大師啊
哪個人 你告訴我哪一個人
下面再幫我留言
是不是哲哲在2023年
說AI股會漲一整年
後來我馬上改成AI股漲三年
誰敢講啊
那時候是劃時代的預測
我現在再跟你講一次
三年內會見10萬點
誰敢講
你們很多人
很多分析師預測點數
一方面是學哲哲
可是他不敢講什麼時間點
我很敢講啊 我跟你講好不好
所以有沒有講
自己說3年內有沒有
有沒有 回答一下有沒有
順便按個讚好不好
今天戒菸28天 來
我知道你還有錢
全球暖化跟AI發展的看法
你這個沒有意義啊
這個大哉問
如果要入門開始放長期
大概要準備多少資金
現在1000元也可以放
如果入門要開始投資的話
說要放多少資金
隨時都可以放
你們還是聽不懂
這個就是你把
就是我的錢
看到錢我放到銀行
我拿到錢存到ETF
就是這樣子的差別而已嘛
哲哲那我需要錢怎麼辦
不能賣喔
隨便你賣啊
又不是不好贖回
又不是賣房子
你房子要找人家賣
要拜託人家 還要找仲介
對不對 是不是
你看有人說有
有沒有看到 是不是有3年前
再多一點吧
批評哲哲 怨恨哲哲 理解哲哲
愛上哲哲 成為哲哲 謝謝你
來 張姓分析師是誰
不要幫他打廣告啦
他也不只欺負我一個啦
知道就知道
這是要講給同業聽啦
打哲哲 打分析師
業績不會比較好
你去看他們的營收
身體不會比較好
那這樣有什麼意義呢
現在是網路時代了
大家看的是你會不會幫人家賺錢
記得這句話
我做不好的時候
自然就不會有會員 來
我是來看偶像 不是來聽股票
我愛你 好不好 OK嗎
技嘉怎麼看
之前說拉回要買
技嘉也不錯
我跟你講
技嘉跟微星最大的問題是
來 第一個
他有點老AI的感覺
就是老電子股的感覺
第二個 他們沒有什麼跌
不然如果就以前的話
如果現在是
技嘉跟微星
如果現在是5萬點
就是你們資金又回來
又1.5兆了
我覺得這種股票會噴
聽得懂嗎
現在資金不夠
中實戶 大戶會選擇那種
打帶跑的股票
我先漲一根再說啦
明天再走啦
或今天漲 今天走啦
這樣懂不懂
今天買 今天盤中就走了
我不想要
因為這種股票
他是少數都準備要創新高的股票
或已經剛創新高的股票
太強了
這一波都沒什麼拉回的股票
他們不一定會喜歡
這樣懂不懂
他的問題是這樣子
所以我寧願選保守
就是我不選那種現在沒有折扣的股票
還沒有折扣
還可能要變更貴
我要選打五折 打六折的
現在一堆 好不好
環球晶就打五折嘛
是不是打六折嘛 是不是
這樣懂不懂 Understand
環球晶今天有拉起來了
尾盤拉起來一點點 有沒有
3532台勝科
看台勝科就知道要噴出去了 好不好
這個跟大家講
所以我們今天看一下恭賀的簡訊 來
順便喝個水
你看以前欣興有沒有看到
100多塊買 300多塊出
跌到7 80的時候被人家罵死了
南亞科49塊買進
跌到40幾塊被人家罵死
有沒有 哲哲上車囉
有沒有 好強 好帥是不是
什麼哲哲南亞科超級帥
是唱這首歌 對不對
你有沒有印象
轉眼間現在討論
今天南亞科500塊 十倍耶
你哪邊 哪個世界
525怎麼辦
我那時候50塊沒有人理我
所以現在國巨也會這樣
你相信我
為什麼今年績效特別好
我就不追高
你喜歡看那種天天漲停板
你要被騙我沒辦法
我就跟你講實在話
那個邏輯不對
如果這樣他應該早就100萬粉絲
200萬粉絲了
我講真的 我也沒有要針對誰
我希望所有分析師
真的要改變這個情況
有些老投顧分析師
觀眾也不是傻瓜
你們真的不是傻瓜
你們要當傻瓜我也沒辦法
國巨千元的學長我們追到你了
OK 好 這個跟大家講
AI能不能變現
都已經要毀滅世界了
還問說會不會變現
AI不能變現代表進步不快
就是可以變現 可以賺錢好不好
台股如果順利5萬
隔壁的日經有沒有機會7萬
你買台灣50就好了
你這麼保守 你買什麼日經的ETF
不用
那就買那斯達克就好了 好不好
或S&P 500就好了
不要那麼複雜
我就跟你講
你不是幾十億身家
不要那麼分散
台灣50已經很分散 你還要再分散
那你買VT就好了
不懂
不懂就聽我講 好不好 拜託
真的我是為你好
來 我們來講我們的簡訊 來看一下
還沒講
南電以前100多塊有沒有看到
景碩90幾塊 有便宜嗎
這是今年的績效
先唸一下世界先進好不好
唸一下好不好
美女導播好不好 來
好 9月18日禮拜五 今天的簡訊
恭喜5347世界
股價已經連三紅
創快兩個月新高
我們多次買進 最高獲利18%
我持續看好它
手上持股抱好抱牢
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
來 恭喜5347的世界先進
股價已經連三紅
創2個月新高
我們多次買進 最高獲利18%
我持續看好它 手上持股抱好抱牢
投資朋友 世界先進有賺喔
賺18%算遜的 丟臉
如果我沒錯的話
有些還在成本附近
沒有什麼賺 沒賺
所以你現在買股票很便宜啊
真的你相信我
嗅不出來嗎
助理還沒有回答我
我到底台灣50賺多少
你看我都把我的 賺的錢喔
置之於生死之外 不在乎它啦
好不好 這個跟大家講
來 我的台灣50賺多少錢
助理還沒有回答我
應該是1900萬到2000萬
那我跟你講說這不要緊
你看喔 台灣
台股的報酬對不對
這幾年台股的報酬 台股喔
除了2022年從18000
大概跌到12000 來
18000跌到12000
它是從年初算到年尾
可是中間是18000跌到12000
跌22%
你看每個都20%報酬
今年62%耶 很屌耶
不好意思用這個字比較粗俗
真的很厲害
62.9%你還不滿意
哲哲 可不可以馬上5萬點
所以它休息很正常
它已經非人哉了
明年還能到6萬點
你不覺得我很敢預告
因為你不懂AI啊
那些分析師只要每天講漲停板
也不用解釋這些東西啊
我為什麼跟你講AI這些東西
我就跟你講這個
慢慢用
你要記得你們不用AI會被人家淘汰
真的很多 好不好
不是我淘汰你們
是會用AI的律師
淘汰不會用AI的律師喔
會用AI的醫生
淘汰不會用AI的醫生喔
我現在看病啊
你看真的還會這樣
那個牙痛喔
有時候你知道
不是要看醫生耶
要看什麼
要看心臟內科
陳建州就是這樣子啊
不是陳建州
你知道為什麼
因為都擴散出去了 血液不通
牙痛 其實可能是心肌梗塞
可能是你要中風了
這邊阻塞就是腦中風
這邊阻塞就是心肌梗塞
這樣懂不懂
你如果
我今天覺得
我知道你們很多人都覺得健康不重要
很多人都是健康沒有了
才知道健康很重要
可是我是為你們好
你們不願意花600塊的訂閱
你知不知道那個
如果你問一下說
不好意思我現在牙痛
你都不問 你只上網搜尋一下牙痛
那你就去看牙科啊 慘了
那個心血管疾病如果發作的時候
你沒有黃金90分鐘內解決
你就Byebye了
就有後遺症了
你去搜尋一下牙痛 問AI
然後我胸口很悶
他一定會回答
我認為他一定會回答說
你有中風危機了
不會叫你去看牙科 你懂不懂
那這個時候
是不是可以幫忙你很多
還有很多醫生也可以幫忙到很多人
菜鳥醫生啊
有經驗的醫生當然知道
可能是心肌梗塞
可是不同科 天壤之別
你聽得懂我的意思嗎
就是你本來以為要看牙科了
醫學好玩的地方
你以為這個徵兆是看這個部位
你還要先去搜尋一下什麼科別
才去掛號什麼東西
你問AI他可以馬上幫你解決很多問題
你有牙痛又有心臟悶
不是 你是要中風
你要死掉了 你要心肌梗塞了
懂不懂
光這個投資差多少
你也不用找家教老師啊
你的小孩夠聰明
直接拍照就好了
夠聰明 也不需要夠聰明
夠正常就好 然後有意志力
不要亂上網
有什麼問題直接拍照
叫他解決就好了
問他為什麼 OK嗎
南亞科是不是有機會變聯發科第二
一路上去
南亞科有機會
南亞科的中實戶 大戶很厲害啊
當然就我認識他
不是就我認識他
但是有一面之緣
這個中實戶
台灣現在最厲害的中實戶了
這個之前金居它是拉起來再殺下去
可是我覺得金居跟南亞科不太一樣
那些記憶體真的會很缺
所以我很難預料它
它想拉或別人想拉
這已經不是
這個很難用技術線型來說
那如果要出掉的話你就看到
每一次可能到569
或是569創新高又下來了
那你就要注意一下
是不是邊拉邊出
可是邊拉邊出也沒什麼不好
為什麼沒什麼不好
像金居 同一個大戶
金居之前是這樣子
這邊邊拉邊出
大概差不多
這邊300的時候邊拉邊出有沒有看到
一直邊拉邊出有沒有
拉上去 拉上去 拉上去有沒有
南亞科之後有可能這樣走
可是殺下去以後對不對
最後 有沒有
行情上去了它照樣再漲上去
就算這邊出掉很多
最後還是漲到400塊
那時候300塊明顯有壓力有沒有看到
後來有第二批的中實戶 大戶去拉它
又漲上去了
你看那時候有上影線有沒有看到
這邊有上影線 來 這邊
懂不懂
有時候為什麼我不喜歡看K線
K線是大戶製造的好不好
K線是大戶玩的好不好
K線是大戶生的好不好
可是K線要不要看
可以看 因為有趨勢
300有沒有 一突破
那時候就有壓力
已經3次有沒有看到
你以為不行了
到最後它還是拉起來
你懂不懂 OK嗎
技術線型一定要參考
但是參考一些就好
絕對不要參考全部
因為大戶可以產出K線圖 好不好
哲哲太強了 醫學常識
這個很簡單
你性騷擾我
沒有啦
哲哲大老闆 當沖見好就收
當沖當然見好就收
因為你最大的壓力是時間成本
不要想那麼多
當沖難度比股票做多難十倍
因為你有資金成本壓力
有時間成本壓力
會當沖的大部分都是沒錢
不然你幹嘛當沖
你為什麼不玩隔日
你有時間壓力
你好好的買股票
你都不一定會賺錢
你還想當沖你會賺錢
這個邏輯就不對了
哲哲能私訊你的特助給建議
賣哪幾支股票來加入會員
這可以啊 這當然可以啊 好不好
可是我們不會直接建議
因為你畢竟又不是我的會員
當然可以啊
你應該這樣講
就是順序是加入會員再問
我們會告訴你
理論上或怎麼樣
應該這樣講
詢問入會的時候
最好的方式是加入會員 好不好
加入會員
然後我給你建議賣什麼股票
好不好 OK嗎
可是你不要靠這個東西來吃豆腐
應該不會啦
你應該是要參加會員
趕快來私訊我 好不好
私訊就加LINE
記得我們加LINE
那個TG
TG也有詐騙的
然後Threads有詐騙的
他們都叫你
用我這個帳號然後叫你加
其實是P圖
圖片都是假的
不要注意圖片
圖片有藍勾勾那都假的
唯一的LINE加進去後
注意一下 每天一定要講一下
沒辦法 現在詐騙集團實在太恐怖了
我檢舉他們 他們還不爽
看一下
這邊 LINE
這個沒有盾牌白勾勾就是假的
其他都多說的
你不要看到這邊盾牌白勾勾
這假的 這是圖片
圖片可以造假
你只要記得圖片都可以造假
不要理他
可是圖片點進去呢
這就不能造假了
這邊已認證不能造假
我唯一官方LINE
現在基本上九成分析師都學我了
我是全國第一個人你有沒有印象
所以我趨勢看很遠
我那時候不是說還吃他們豆腐嗎
我說其他分析師都學我們摩爾
有啊 對不對
你有沒有發現我預測很多
你要選就選最紅 不找我找誰
要噴出去了啦
今天有教你們大戶怎麼做股票喔
好不好 來
晚上11點到凌晨1點
對 時間也很重要
有沒有機會直接去公司加入會員
也可以啊
你公司地點都找得到啊 好不好
可以加入會員純聊天嗎
有些會員是這樣子
哲哲你好厲害
我純粹加入你的會員支持你
我支持你
那你要不要參考
可以 但是我最主要是支持你
我覺得你很厲害
這種我不少會員
我很多會員是粉絲型的
這才是真正的粉絲的
不是說你們不算
我就想加入你的會員
我就想支持你
你要不要開發票隨便你
他可能丟了錢要走
不行 不行 不行
我們要開發票
我們是合法的
不要挖洞給我跳
我們不可能不開發票 好不好
如果不開發票你跟我講
這個有刻意不開發票的人
我一定請他走人
一定 一定
就純粹我丟了錢就好了
那個不用開發票也行
不行 不行
我很多純粉絲就是
好像那個Sponsor
贊助我而已啦 開心
不用 不用
謝謝你啦
就是按照程序把它做完 好不好
夜盤繼續噴 這個跟大家講
我們來看一下
哲哲你很屌 到處都用你的照片
我好累喔 來
你看夜盤又噴了
來 我昨天為什麼說會噴
我就說期貨很重要
這幾天為什麼有把握
第一個 結算見轉折
第二個 期貨正價差很多
200點 400點
我們再看一次
現在47180
已經漲那麼多了
今天漲892點
來看右邊 今天漲892點 放大
47180 現在47542
正價差還有360點
盤後繼續漲
你看不出來大戶回來了嗎
其實從頭到尾
前陣子就是結算見轉折
所以你現在的價差
你現在很多股票打5折
你應該開心啊
你要惜福啊 各位
就像那些人奇怪
欣興的時候
什麼搞個自救會來罵我
70塊你要謝謝我
是不是 還有很多人可以加碼
我那時候逢低還加碼
是真的 我不是說
我厚顏無恥的講實在話
我看的長度跟你們不同
結果現在每次問我
天上的欣興不說話
1000塊跌到900塊叫不說話
去年的70塊
900塊你就受不了
時間拉長一點就發現
這沒什麼
談笑風生
這樣懂不懂我的意思
看我的節目就是修身養性
你們運氣很好
今天要不是有AI
我可以臭屁成這樣子
可是也要我看得懂趨勢
我就是那個豬
豬站在風口上也會飛
但我絕對是那種
站在最大風口上的豬
這樣講自己是稱讚自己嗎
但是我不管
我絕對知道哪個風往哪邊吹
那個風最大我就站在那邊
不論是LINE的趨勢
TG的趨勢
Threads的趨勢
YouTube的趨勢
哪一個我不是站在第一波主流的
你告訴我
還有認證的趨勢
到最後都要學習我 模仿我啊
是啊 模仿我們摩爾
是 你要相信我AI這個都很誇張
所以你告訴大家好不好
下次有開自救會罵哲哲的股票
一定要All in
而且我選的都是有價有量的股票
來 這個跟大家講
欣興的怨念
不是啊 因為我覺得不是
我跟你講
因為那些有些人是我之前
說老實話有些是我的粉絲
有些是我的會員
可是我要說老實話
我很難過的是
那些攻擊我的同業
因為他們攻擊你
你覺得他們欣興70塊會抱著嗎
不會啊 不會抱著
可是我就是死抱活抱
有人講放久也會漲
胡扯 有些人就放不久
放久也是一種能耐
而且一年 而且不要說一年
我也沒真的
因為我沒有到900塊啊
我300多塊走啊
100多%也可以啦
好不好 所以要記得這件事
現在幾分
精材也要噴了啦
精材的中實戶很強耶
跟你講 好不好
這些股票都要噴了
其實我這樣
我就這幾支股票啦
我現在不想新的股票
是因為我不想要去追創新高的
因為我現在就是要保守
我只要環球晶你現在跟著我
然後創新高
900塊回到1600
就回到這邊就好了
我什麼都不要
我就賺60%了
不止喔 快70%
賺65%以上喔
什麼都不要
是不是 這個跟大家講
所以你去想想看
你要怎樣的分析師好不好
OK嗎 來
這件事情就是這樣子 來
還有一樣環球晶來看一下
環球晶你不用擔心
3532台勝科也是一樣
我就說圍魏救趙
這些股票拉起來就是這樣
台勝科強
你說環球晶不會強嗎
信昌電都要創新高
我跟你講 甚至國巨
老虎不發威 你當病貓喔
我跟你講
沒有關係啦
反正看我的節目
中實戶 大戶很多啦
他們現在不敢動
等到哪一天受不了
拉國巨給你看 我跟你講
到時候都會缺
你要想想看
都已經可以考慮到毀滅世界了
進展多快
我再給你看一個八卦
你看我做很多圖 來
你看我每天做那麼多圖 你看
講不完你看
還有台灣50生效
這個講不完
你看我很認真
這是For今天而已 好不好
你看央行的力道 有沒有
央行做這個圖
好 你不要跳了
有這個 這張圖對不對
還有一張圖 這是AI做的圖
這個啦 Claude對不對
Anthropic
這Claude談話的很爛
但是寫程式很強
Claude怎麼樣
今年不到1%
用AI研發AI 不到1%
現在26% 以後是100%
有好有壞
因為AI比人類強 比人類聰明
你們要能接受AI比你強
比你聰明
你要接受你的渺小 你才能成長
你要接受你自己撐不住
你才能持久
好像賣藥
這樣懂嗎 26%
很多耶 以後會變AI研發AI
AI研發AI就是我講指數型的成長
越來越多人說
我3年前就這樣說了
不覺得很恐怖嗎
這些股票 這些都送分題
我感覺要噴出去 你沒感覺到嗎
助理 我的台灣50到底賺多少
賺1800萬有沒有看到
0050賺1800多萬有沒有看到
還好啦
創新高考慮就00981A
因為有部分人是聽我話買00981A
00981A最近比較爛
等它突破前高的時候
32塊左右的時候
你再去換台灣50不錯
現在換也可以
現在應該是漲的比台灣50多
差距拉近了
因為一開始是00981A
就是中小型股拉很多
所以你看00981A就知道
很多中小型股沒有漲
一開始它彈的比大盤快
有沒有看到
這是00981A
這0050代表權值股
現在權值股比較強
有沒有看到
這是0050
這是00981A
這樣懂不懂
那這個差距
這個我剛才講這兩個差距
就是你現在要賺錢的空間
所以00981A下個禮拜也有機會漲
你們如果懂我這樣子價差
那你可以買00981A
你不懂要買什麼股票
你懂我在說什麼嗎
不懂就算了 不懂就不要買
就不要買主動型ETF
我有分層次的好不好
最後要結束了 幾分 導播
49差不多了好不好
華邦電一樣
這個華邦電
下次190就會噴出去了
我跟你講
這邊創新高
這邊190就噴出去
再重複一次
不要說我沒說 好不好
群聯今天也拉起來了
群聯今天講第三次了
有沒有看到 群聯拉起來
我們用群聯2000元以下 OK啦
你不要因為老闆一直出來講話
覺得很討厭
帆宣看起來也不錯
帆宣這一根看起來是要噴出去
帆宣很牛皮
所以帆宣跟台積電資本支出概念股
這兩個都一樣
精材我都蠻看好
你看不出來我的股票要噴出去了嗎
台灣50我大獲全勝
賺1800萬 沒關係
我年底還要捐一台救護車
到明年是賺5000萬
6萬點的話
我要捐第三台救護車
每一台救護車大概500多萬 好不好
我最大的快樂是來自於
大家都賺到錢
然後我也賺到錢
然後回饋社會
我希望你能感受到我的熱忱
很多股票要噴出去了
大盤在這邊
很多股票在這邊
這個價差就是未來的獲利空間
你去想想看我講的對不對
如果想清楚的話
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE
我剛剛有講過
上面有盾牌加白色勾勾
沒有就是假的
有你就盡量問
哲哲怎麼加入會員
哲哲加入會員我要賣哪些股票
你們都可以來問我
加入會員以後
當然可以盡量問 好不好
如果真的有一些問題
也可以來問我
會費多少加我的LINE
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
我愛大家
現在轉眼間要48000
會不會下禮拜5萬點
我跟你講5萬點
今年5萬點只是基本的
我的預測都是基本的
今年預測能力多強
你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
也歡迎大家怎麼樣
來電洽詢0800668085
0800來來幫你幫我
或者加我的LINE私訊我
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
今天一堆股票大漲
甚至準備創新高
趕快掌握下一波行情
不要等到台灣股市突破5萬點
甚至突破6萬點才後悔
預祝各位能夠賺大錢